[Music]
the production of the mad max prequel
furiosa is already in full swing however
a new crew change is already on the
horizon as deadline reports a still
unknown role has been recast the talk is
about they're all played by abdulmedian
ii who appears to see no future for
himself and mad max due to scheduling
difficulties the reason for this is the
early production of a new project of his
which he did not want to specify at in
addition he is still starring as the dc
villain black manta and dc's aquaman and
the lost kingdom thus leaving the mad
max prequel is very understandable this
decision was unfavorable for those in
charge since shooting is expected to
start very soon possibly even this year
nevertheless action was taken very
quickly as deadline also reported on the
new cast immediately accordingly the
role will be filled by tom burke who is
known from david fincher's mank or the
new drama true things details regarding
the story are still scarce the only
clear thing is that the film revolves
around the resistance fight of furiosa
and that it will be significantly more
extensive than the original the main
role in the blockbuster which will cover
several years will be played by anya
dela joy who will be accompanied by
hollywood superstar chris hemsworth in
his role as dementis through the desert
landscape the release of mad max furiosa
is still a long way off as the movie is
not due to be released until may 24 2024
though this is no surprise given the
traditionally elaborate production
nicholas cage definitely has quite a
reputation in hollywood the 57 year old
is known above all for his quirky
performance and even quirkier films in
the last few years mainly from the
independence sector recently however he
has also been able to star in less
trashy productions including for example
the well-made drama pig or the horror
film prisoners of the ghostland which
also received mostly positive reviews
now he continues with an equally spooky
story as cage has been signed on to play
dracula in universal's vampire movie
renfield judging by the name the story
will not focus primarily on the world's
most famous vampire but on his sidekick
rm renfield in the original book by bram
stoker the patient of a psychiatric
hospital is obsessed with the thought of
becoming immortal nicholas holt has been
cast for the role of renfield and it is
said that the movie will put the
emphasis on comedy and action rather
than on horror elements the script of
renfield was written by robert kirkman
and ryan ridley while the tomorrow war
director chris mckay will be directing
the film in addition to nicholas holt
aquafina is also reportedly part of the
cast though her exact role remains
unknown in any case we are already
looking forward to the eerily funny
performance of nicolas cage as dracula
and we cannot wait to learn more about
the production of renfield
well it's no secret that tom cruise
movies are traditionally very stunt
heavy what makes it special is that the
actor does most of the stuns himself
which always results in some vertigonous
shots currently cruz is in the uk for
the shooting of mission impossible 8 and
that is where he likewise performed a
new daring maneuver attached only by
safety harness he was hanging from a
small plane at times even upside down
while the aircraft performed loops and
other maneuvers multiple times all of
this took place in part at an altitude
of more than 600 meters so kudos to the
59 year old actor mission impossible 7
will be released in theaters on
september 30th 2022 while its successor
mission impossible 8 will not be
released until july 7 2023
actually it has been clear for some time
that tom holland and his version of
spider-man will leave the mcu after the
upcoming no way home the emphasis is on
actually because no way home producer
amy pascal unexpectedly announced that
tom holland will remain in the mcu
pascal also the former co-chairman of
sony pictures stated in all clarity that
they are already making preparations for
the next spider-man film with tom
holland behind the scenes and if that
wasn't enough she specified her
statement saying that this movie will be
part of a new mcu trilogy this news
comes more or less out of nowhere and
caused great anticipation throughout the
fan community of course tom holland also
could not help but comment on the whole
thing holland who is at present on a
worldwide promotional tour for no way
home was immediately interviewed about
the upcoming trilogy during an
appearance on the french tv program
quotidion but it's expected he had to
maintain a low profile according to him
there's some very exciting things to be
discussed but he has no idea where
exactly that will lead
the most important question will
probably be how sony and marvel will
deal with the rights to spider-man in
the future since a return to the sony
universe was being planned soon it's
conceivable that spider-man might switch
back and forth between the two universes
or that both companies could release
their films independently of each other
although that would admittedly be a bit
confusing so what are your thoughts what
could another trilogy in the mcu look
like or how could the two universes be
made consistent with each other feel
free to let us know in the comments
spider-man no way home is scheduled for
release on december 17 2021 should also
keep your eyes open for news about
spider-man into the spider-verse 2
because amy pascal revealed that they
will be showing something new about the
animated spectacle very soon
many fans actually expected a new
trailer for sonic the hedgehog 2 on
thanksgiving in the end this obviously
did not happen but as the renowned
insider big screen leaks announced on
twitter the first trailer has already
been compiled and is slightly more than
two minutes long so there's a lot to
suggest that paramount will release the
trailer some time before christmas
though an exact date is hard to figure
out at least we will most likely get a
first look at knuckles who will be
dubbed by idris elba apart from that jim
carrey is back as dr robotnik james
marston antique sumter as the wakowski
couple colin o'shaughnessy takes on the
role of tales and last but not least ben
schwartz returns as sonic of course
sonic the hedgehog 2 will release on
april 8 2022.
for a long time there was no news about
the upcoming batgirl from dc but now it
looks like things are getting underway
as director adil rb recently posted a
first said image on instagram to see is
the traditional first clap aboard
moreover we can take a first look at the
uniform of the gotham city police
department with this the events are
coming thick and fast because just a
week ago they were still saying that
shooting would probably finally kick up
soon however it was not foreseeable that
this would happen that soon after the
long production hell similarly
surprising was the return of actor jk
simmons who announced the news of the
imminent start of shooting last week he
himself was said to be all a flutter
when he was asked to play the role of
commissioner gordon again allegedly the
role of the commissioner will be
considerably more important than in the
batman films for instance but
unfortunately simmons did not reveal any
more details the primary setting for
batgirl is the scottish poor city of
glasgow where by the way a large part of
the batman was shot particularly the
many gothic elements of the city give
the gloomy story something special and
does fit perfectly with batgirl and
batman regarding the script there is
considerably less information than about
the filming spot all that is really
known is that commissioner gordon will
play a more prominent role as the
protagonist's father apparently it looks
as if batgirl will be released next year
but a more accurate date has not been
determined yet
the power rangers have been winning the
hearts of children all over the world
since 1993. in over 750 episodes and
three movies the power rangers have been
protecting the world from evil yet the
big step into the modern streaming
business was missing last year rumors
first surfaced that a power rangers
cinematic universe would soon be
established and as a few days ago it
became clear in which context
accordingly netflix secured their rights
to the next power rangers movie
more precisely a reboot production has
been reportedly been underway since 2020
and will be directed by jonathan and
whistle with brian edward hill handling
the script in terms of content the film
revolves around time travel back to the
1990s as the power rangers try to return
to the era of the beginnings in the
course of this the brand new power
ranger cinematic universe will be
introduced on netflix and of course will
be featured with more series and movies
in the future e1 president michael
lombardo also expresses his delight at
having entrusted power rangers to
jonathan and wizzle and holds out the
prospect of several series along with
some children's formats we can only hope
that the project will not flop as much
as the power rangers movie from 2017
what exactly the universe will look like
then as well as a release date for the
first film is not yet known
we hope you enjoyed our news this week
if you happen to be into cyberpunk you
might be interested to know more about a
sequel to alita battle angel in that
case be sure to check out our latest
original and if that is not enough make
sure to check out the new trailer for
the matrix 4 resurrections
[Music]